hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to night blights now
I'm sorry for taking so long to get back
to this game I had a lot of things that
got in the way including trips going
down to comic-con a whole bunch of stuff
but now I'm back into it and you guys
definitely want to see more there was so
much demand for it I really am impressed
by it so in this new night that I'm
doing I gotta remember that the baby
fills them with glee and they're gonna
eat it and then for some reason the
garage door will be opened and then I
need to press the red button to keep the
door shut tight so that's already two
more things on top of everything else
that I need to remember which is
probably not a good thing because there
was a lot of things going on the first
one but hopefully it's not gonna be all
that much if your baby brother begins to
cry be sure to spin his mobile quickly
well maybe he should just shut up and
learn to deal I've got enough things on
my mind enough stress in my life okay so
the garage door is now open that's
downstairs the big red button yeah man
wouldn't the garage door opening meaning
that my my parents were coming home and
perhaps
mayhaps that was a good thing okay so
either way let me position things I
don't need up here this needs to be over
here okay so I need to stack a whole
bunch of toys ready to sacrifice to
anything in the two bedrooms I gotta
watch the closets like that I gotta
watch the closets oh man
it's so many things to keep track of why
do I need to do this I am a toddler I am
a baby God why is this necessary
alright whatever no you don't I hear you
over there yeah it's still disconcerting
that there is no music but also that
kind of adds a little bit of an element
to it and that it's like well maybe I'm
probably gonna die because I have no
idea what's going on at any time
that's that looks familiar is that from
rocket power what was that what was that
I don't know what that was is that the
garage I might have been the garage
crap that's a lot of stuff happening how
I'm supposed to survive it
this whole dose of the garage okay
no no I said no thanks for honking at me
ghosts what if you're right and they're
wrong
oh no don't give those existential
questions to a toddler what do I know
I'm a baby I gotta get moving I'm moving
too slow I can afford a little bit of
sprinting here and there but for the
most part just generally keep things
kind of tight okay so I got a check on
the dam and I'll get to you in a second
you're just gonna have to wait for a bit
because I got all the priorities right
now okay
crap crap crap crap okay gotta go
upstairs okay there was nothing else
that I forgot right that was the other
thing the baby crying that's right
there's there's a baby now apparently
okay
so there's some cabinet upstairs it's
also Creek cracking I need of it why are
my parents faceless I get it I know
feed you your greedy Gus all right take
a little bit of this
yum yum shut up okay so that's that I
need to bring at least one more toy from
downstairs to upstairs so hopefully I
can get that taken care of okay close
that I'm gonna grab that toy you shut up
well.all crap already
Jesus okay gimme gimme gimme goddamnit
there we go okay on the way back down on
the way back down baby bro don't start
crying right now cuz garage doors
opening yeah can you stay there that's
closed I get it yeah I know Jesus is
stressful for some reason this is more
stressful than I thought it'd be all
things considered all right come on I
know I know I don't even think the
kitchen would make some noise no no no
no no no
no no oh no no no no no no no no no no
you did not do none of that okay let me
just check on the kitchen real quick
and hopefully I can grab something on
the way I don't know if I can it might
be too high up crap crap crap crap crap
crap crap crap holy crap holy oh crap
come on I don't know if I have to do I
not have a lot of time oh that's a good
sound that's not good
oh I'm a common burro sister I don't
remember row baby whatever baby I'm
coming oh don't cry don't cry - oh I see
you up there I saw that yeah shut up oh
god did I move this I'll move this okay
I got I got I got I got I got I got buh
buh buh buh buh bah bah bah bah shut up
bah bah buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh
buh buh okay goddamn a little too much
for me to handle right now okay so the
one in hue
okay everything seems to be handled
fairly well it's everything everything
good wrap god damn they like that garage
is it is a little weird how that music
keeps playing what this isn't even open
oh it's open a tiny buddy Jesus don't do
that
spooky Oh what is that all about it's
supposed to be open why is there a toy
in here no oh it was a trap
Oh polo me up hold on you oh oh you
bastard
this is a bastard oh you bastard
oh you rat bastard I'll be rat bastard
oh you son of a [ __ ] oh crap okay I
don't think it's gonna give me the like
notification that oh there's the door
open somewhere maybe can't carve that
you idiot fool okay hmm no no no you
close close they do close okay I think I
heard the garage moving right after yep
okay I did I did hear that
Todd damn that car those car bastards
okay come on now it's almost open
oh that was almost open this is too
stressful too stressful can't that
upstairs who is that down here I think
that might have been upstairs I don't
think there's been one down here hazard
it's double check just in case you never
know okay was not you okay not you gotta
go upstairs they're closed
okay we're doing good we're doing good
that might have been the kitchen door
but I just closed it recently so I think
it'll be okay okay feed you feed you
feed you feed you feed you video gamer
can I get it you're greedy Gus can we
give give okay
yum yum yum go to hell okay we're good
we're good we're good we're good
we're good we're good we're so good okay
we're good I got stopped running so much
I'm not sure what my limitations are but
damn it I'm gonna I'm gonna do this just
in case I don't know if no I can't even
do it
not until it starts crying oh crap I
gotta go straight again little horsey
disease hey I'm a grizzled veteran of a
toddler I'm just a little puff baby I've
seen some [ __ ] maybe three years
but I've been through the swamps of
Vietnam I know it
Charlie's up to you I couldn't remember
the name been so long ago back when I
was to God years go by when you're
[ __ ] a Vietnam vet baby I can't tell
you the horrors that I've seen but I'm
reliving them every day my parents don't
even understand heck some days I don't
even think I understand anymore but as a
gril veteran baby I don't really know
there's only one thing standing between
my family and these horrible monsters
that's me and I am 16 Daisy they better
not man with me well they're gonna mess
with Daisy yeah
Ashley damn sure yeah yeah my name but
Rick okay good got that name al the way
that was it hard at all oh no Heisenberg
again what's with Heisenberg I don't
even know what that's about
okay 6:00 a.m. I've only got one more
hour to go through man I spent all my
brainpower trying to come up with a name
for Rick the toddler Vietnam vet baby
okay give that all right Karl everything
seems to be roughly under control I just
got to go downstairs make sure
everything isn't [ __ ] have I checked on
the kitchen in a while would I don't
know if I did that whoo I gotta go I
think I did I'm pretty sure I did
oh crap was it why do I hear that what
is that what is it
I heard like a persistent growling why
this great little veteran Joe doc dad
this Corso veteran knows better that's
actually fine why did I hear a growling
I didn't leave anything open god damn it
why do I hear that growling upstairs I
don't hear a baby crying the closet one
was closed the one in the upstairs
bedroom was closed hi
oh god why he's right there why is he
right there why why was he right there
okay
Wednesday's flights are unclean in
relish and grime so up the toilet cripes
they will sometimes climb cross them
away as quick as you can
else breathing round corners will be
there great plan some nights I'll set
the fire alight use the bellow to be
safe on your tear filled flight four
should the fire be left to wither and
die then hiding round corners the
blights will know all right
slaps night blights little a night too
so I might just play this to completion
if you guys really want to see it's an
interesting game there's a lot of
elements here this is adding two more
things that I need to worry about that
weren't in the original equation so it's
a lot of things to juggle a lot of traps
apparently I'd only cut in the car again
that was terrifying
so thank you everybody so much for
watching click the annotation for scary
videos that I've done and as always I
will see
in the next video
you